it's one thing to be an elite athlete at
the top of sport but then on top of that
also to have like a robust professional
career and have kids and a family like
how does that jigsaw puzzle work for you
I think the biggest thing is I really
want to do it I've always wanted to meet
my obligations and still like Chase
these like big audacious streams and
goals and so like I remember when my
wife and I got engaged like all my
running friends were like oh your
running is going to go downhill yeah
like it's you don't want to do it like
it's it's almost impossible to do it and
and I think a lot of people come up with
reasons why they can't do something and
I look for more reasons why you can do
something and so like I hope when people
see me now they're like well if that
dude with like the family and the job
and you know all these other commitments
can do it like maybe I can do it too